hey see you hey Danny I am in love with
this phone oh yeah it's beautiful look
at this is the motorola zn5 mm-hmm and I
think it's gorgeous kidless keypad
minutes it's it's awesome if you like
that keep it I like this keypad it's you
know it's back wit it's a little bit
funky but once you get used to it it's
it's it's not bad at all yeah you like
the touch buttons I like to touch
buttons and i also like this 5 megapixel
camera it's in this guy right here yeah
have you have you actually taking
pictures with it I just did really yeah
have you compared it to the photos that
this guy takes oh I haven't you have it
d is that the NAD to you got there this
is the nokia n82 that is pretty much I
think the gold standard for the last
year and a half in camp well that is the
highest rated camera phone we've it is
it is our highest camera phone it got an
8 out of 10 in tests and what do you
think you think this is it's going to
unseat this guy I'm kind of hoping that
it well you think so yeah okay well I
hate to burst your bubble but
essentially despite what you think about
how beautiful that hardware is not not
the better all right so what
specifically what's wrong with the
camera let's start with the positives
right oh sorry well I see that the
that's the trouble you got right there
your wallpaper in there this dog it's
pretty yes so basically here's the thing
so right moto Motorola has done you know
a pretty nice job with integrating the e
rocker so it's the same very similar
face so you've got these beautiful kind
of purplish you know back Hughes it
looks like you're flying on virgin
america told you like that sort des
impression that I got I thought about
your Branson was going to come up give
me that phone totally it's the Branson
phone right les hommes and it's cool you
know you flip it to the side it's it's
significantly thinner and yeah now this
is a little this is a chunky monkey
right here right yeah 82 right and this
is thin this is this is very thin right
at least you know fifty percent thinner
and it's got the beautiful kind of
purple shoot but I'm like you know it's
got a lot of things that are sexy
whereas this isn't so sexy this is this
is more of a brick in your pants okay so
well this has a Carl Zeiss lens on it
now you know who that guy is he right
nav carl zeiss all right so the biggest
thing and this is why our hopes were so
high for this thing is that the it has
an integrated Kodak lens which is which
is huge I mean this is the first time
motorola so it's done kodak actually
built lens flows camp kodak built
basically scaled down one of their five
megapixels cameras lenses and basically
they just popped it into the they just
dropped it into the rocker they dropped
it like a rocker ok side by side you
stacking these pictures up against each
other that's the problem I mean the more
and more we started to look at these
photos side-by-side noisy so I mean
again I hate to rain on your parade
because well you just did as a phone
it's not bad it's not I I was using it
to make calls and call followed who's
actually pretty clear it did have have
full bars in areas that are notorious
for not having good self mojo bars I'm
sure especially my house right which is
a old San Francisco Victorian there's a
lot of lead paint the walls so it's kind
of hard to get a signal sometimes again
I'm gonna come back and rain on your
parade a little bit more why do you keep
doing that because that's my job oh um
so with this guy you've got all this
control on the zoom so you can kind of
tweak it in you can tweak it out you
have just putt most control ok this guy
you've got preset zooms so you basically
can do a standard shop you can zoom it
in once you can zoom in again and that's
it why don't mind motorola tell me what
i like and can't and not like right
motorola can tell me what to do
knowledge is all just follow that's fine
fine go that then that's a perfect
device for you ok I'm ashamed of you I'm
at the deep end of the pool you know
you're at the shallow a cool this is the
first iteration in the motorola zine
line that they're going to do ok there
will be more phones like this absolutely
okay i mean i hope that they're gonna
kind of set the bar a little bit higher
um it will the next bar be a candy bar
it is not going to be a slider ok so
they're not gonna slide they're gonna
set the bar high they're gonna set the
slider iron and i think i think that
this is this is their first you know
sort of you know step in the right
direction ok and I'm excited to see what
they come out with me
if they're still real if they're still
around right going purely off the images
I'm gonna give it you know six out of
ten okay so it's recommended just with
reservations so certain people who are
maybe shallow and me vapid yeah that's
you might like this phone not to insult
you no no no it's fine that's the
desecurity totally and right you know
mr. boring uh you know pc guy over here
right really likes what his images look
like and doesn't care if it's a
beautiful piece of hardware as much as
you do mm-hmm I'm you care about what's
on the inside I care about what yes I do
yeah so I'm all about flashy looks and
you know a pretty face okay so in my
hand right here i have the new motorola
razr this is the 2008 version and in my
hand i have the 2004 version of the
motorola race it's basically the same
2.2 inch screen same keypad there's
really nothing new about this phone
right Slater right it's kind of like
lipstick on a pig right you gussy it up
with maybe some new building materials
like this one has aluminum glass on it
and we put like a shiny touch screen on
the front and mirror finish and it's and
you release it for a hundred dollars on
sprint and see who will buy it will buy
right it made me kind of angry actually
um yeah all right I feel I feel like
you're angry there's something sort of
disingenuous about motorola basically
releasing the same phone four years
later they've had plenty of times
especially in sort of technology years
this is like the evolution almost the
touch screen itself only registers
touching in three specific areas of the
phone for instance if you press the
button and go to the shortcuts list you
actually have to use the side bar to
scroll through your options on the side
so it's completely gonna take that's
ridiculous redonkulous really that is
redonkulous the kids are saying these
days motorola did actually add a 3.5
millimeter headphone jack on the side
which is nice since this phone is at
least capable of playing music how did
it work as a music player um it's awful
actually because
the old version of the razor of course
used Motorola's music store which
doesn't wasn't all that great to begin
with actually now switch to sprint music
store which is somehow even worse it's
nowhere near what a multimedia phone
music store should be it's horrible a
different team that's who is Lamartine
it is oh man that's terrible is your
Minotaur there there is you have to
fight them actually to access your music
that's terrible yeah today I want to
sign up for two year contract if you
wanted to sign up for two year contract
with sprint it would cost you a hundred
dollars you'll get this phone which is
also kind of puzzling yeah it seems like
this like what the feature set and what
they have here like how much will you be
comfortable pains kind of say zero yeah
the razor was never even good to begin
with they just sort of take one feature
that was poor and released a newer
version that's slightly better so if
there are any razor fans out there um
you know they'll be familiar with sort
of crappiness so this is like a for
hardcore razor fans who will have their
already left who are also looking to get
a sprint contract exactly and who want
sort of like I'm here to look into I
want to use this near to see below my
Aircraftman i'm like stuck of the night
that's right don't wear hey I can blind
our cameraman keep added me with sizes
you